il pourrait vous tuer d'un coup de tête
mais n'ayez crainte le patch icfa lozeau
russe est herbivore
c'est plutôt du t-rex que vous devriez
avoir peur c'est l'un des plus
redoutables carnivores terrestres dans
un parcours le parc de thoiry emmène ses
visiteurs au temps des dinosaures
évidemment à ces dinosaures bouge remue
crash de l'eau comme derrière nos éructe
eux font du bruit tout ça pour le
bonheur des petits et des plus grands
c'est un peu du star les dinosaures et
puis ça à leur place dans un zoo après
tout puisque nous sommes là pour montrer
le vivent tous les vivants les vivants
animés tels qu'ils étaient à toutes les
époques
une exposition version 2 qui compte
quelques nouveautés les apprentis
paléontologues peuvent maintenant
s'exercer sur le camp de fouilles et les
plus aventuriers plonge au coeur du
crétacé grâce à un procédé de réalité
virtuelle
on voit une sorte de ptérodactyle on
voit un dinosaure avec un bec de
perroquet tout le monde croit que les
t-rex c'est un des principal dinosaures
sauf qu'il ya eu des dinosaures
aventurex et ça parle de ce dinosaure
comme ça là on est dedans c'est à dire
qu'on se tourne à 360 degrés en
regardant bas en haut et on voit des
dinosaures partout et on va pas spoiler
la fin mais c'est vrai que
on vit le truc à fond et pour les
enfants c'est génial et pour les adultes
aussi donc c'est parfait
créé par la société anime à tours cette
attraction est accessible au tarif de 5
euros
les visiteurs ont jusqu'à fin septembre
pour profiter des différentes
installations
peut-être les dinosaures se
laisseront-ils car ici
[Musique]